so
so
we go
so
what's up guys
happy wednesday good morning
uh my name is david ahmadi i will be
your host today trying to fight
a bunch of behemoths man it's it is the
operation monarch event in call of duty
war zone so
the goal is we're going to try and hop
in have some fun and
see if godzilla and kong can uh duke it
out and i guess we're even gonna shoot
some of them so that could be fun um
if you guys
can be
my
eyes and ears let me know how the game
audio sounds let me know how my mic
sounds and i can literally just uh
um
tweak those uh those settings for you
you know and we'll be
we'll be good here for about an hour and
a half see what the deal is what's going
on with this live event and let's just
have some fun so
uh supposedly there was supposed to be a
update
and i think i downloaded it already
yesterday so we should be good to go
um
but i'm talking to a couple of my
buddies trying to see if they've had a
install an update real quick or if
there's like a special mode kind of like
how fortnite does its live events or if
we just hop into battle royale
so
we're gonna find out
so one of my friends just said that uh
yeah no update so far so let's just
[ __ ] hop right into it let's go in
some
battle royale solos and
see how fast it takes me to get to the
gulag yeah
as an fyi too actually i saw a uh a
notification
on
uh saw a notification on the battlenet
um client saying that servers might be
up and down because a bunch of people
are obviously gonna try to like
you know they all wanna hop into the
mode and see what's going on
so i'm just trying to
try to see what we got
i'm actually getting a message saying
that um
that there is an update but
let's hop into a match and see what's up
so we're actually live on all platforms
too so those of you who are joining us
on twitch on youtube uh you guys are all
in the same place now so i can see
i can see everyone
uh everyone's chat which is nice
you know usually in the past when i'd be
streaming for for a game spot
uh we'd only see the youtube chat so
those of you on on our other channels
would kind of be
kind of you know left out left out of
all the fun
but i can see all you guys so hello
hello to you bouncy rhythm seven seven
five good morning to you
and my clear it is noon on the east
coast yeah it is morning for me so
i'm pacific boy
what i want to know is for those of you
in the chat if you if you had to pick
universe on the line all the money you
own in the world on the line who would
win godzilla or king kong
i mean for those of you say king kong i
think you're wrong but you know i
digress
just point shoot and have fun buddy that
is the plan man we're gonna see
we're gonna see
what we got
a little training mode going in
got some full lobbies though
some target practice
[Laughter]
oh we got a lot of godzilla's in the uh
a lot of godzilla's in the chat
i'll see y'all uh
so once again yeah just let me know how
it sounds so because in my ear right now
the volume is actually pretty loud so i
might lower it a bit
but if that means i have to
you know raise it up in obs or something
i can totally do that so
get that down to like here
all right i don't know how much of a
delay there is but if i chad you should
just tell me where uh where to drop down
otherwise i'm just gonna drop down on
peak
so actually no i hate peak uh let's go
fields
game's a little low on stream okay no
worries i'll uh i'll raise that in just
a sec
um after i find
some safety i'll uh i'll pop the the
game volume up
aaron says operation monarch mode is
live now leave the match [ __ ] all right
well i guess uh
i guess if i'm gonna leave the match i
might as well just uh dive bomb yeah
here we go
goodbye goodbye cruel world
oh never gets old okay so i'm backing
out and let me uh let me raise the game
volume just a tad
thank you bob jones
good to see you by the way
oh this has got to be the cutscene
oh yeah this is it for sure
let's go
operation monarch titans godzilla and
are unleashed on the island be wary the
arrogance of man is thinking nature is
in their control
you got a titan scream device moniker
set up camp to research the titans
collect intel oh yeah so if you like
shoot the titans enough you get like a
special device and i guess it's like a
kill streak capable and you can
you can take control of the titan
so
don't put them in a frenzy stagger the
times with heavy weaponry and monarch
may compensate you this is like some
like
i don't know it's like the avengers
should have signed a contract or
something to deal with with something
like this
uh
okay so where is this
game mode
oh here we go okay yeah 14 days
uh it's a 14 day limited time event so
we're gonna
play
that i guess
oh weird it's just putting me back to
battle royale
um
let's see real quick
let me pull up my
client and see
okay it's just taking me back to the
battle rail so i'm going to load it in
again i'll see if it's different and
then if it's not i'll just uh reset the
game super quick
you said the game fully okay yeah let me
do that real quick then
we're gonna we're gonna give that a
quick shot
we'll do just give that a quick little
look right there
you guys get to hang out with me for a
bit
all right
so rest of chat let me know how you guys
are doing
how are we feeling today
okay i don't see any updates that's some
good news so we're just going to reset
ben lindsey
seems like he's already in
i don't know if i believe you bro
it's just your word
pds do you fight king kong in this yeah
i think you do man you either fight you
either fight king kong or you fight uh
uh godzilla
that's like one or the other you know
i like this music man
it's uh it's a mood
hopefully i don't have to install like
two gigs of
shaders play operation monarch oh here
we go yeah yeah up top boom
we in it now
game audio solo okay
no worries
you know we um
we test these these streams out before
we uh we start the day before
and you know sometimes it just gets
wonky right like
uh the audio setting seemed fine in my
headset yesterday
but um
you know that's why i got you guys right
y'all are my my eyes and ears
so yeah someone's talking about the
actual movie so i haven't even i
actually haven't seen either of them i
remember seeing the the og gogeta when i
was uh
when i was a kid
i want to see god's delivers kong man
steph you can absolutely get a shout out
thanks for joining the stream bro
soldier nearby
a 60 uh
60 person server
it's a far cry
it's a far cry from the usual 150.
it's the loudest hell in my ear so i'm
going to lower this down
even more
and i'll be sure to uh to raise it in
obs for you guys
[Applause]
what's my melee set to f
what
just downloaded the game what's the meta
man your guess is as good as mine
honestly
i won't be real with you
we might make a video on that though or
we should
see what the the call of duty meta is
so for those of you don't know actually
so i'm uh
i started out as a game play
video producer and i'm a full
full-on video producer for gamespot and
i do a lot of like shooters battlefields
overwatch destiny fortnite you know and
we're always looking for for new angles
and new hooks and popular games to cover
so now i'm back on war zone even though
i you know barely barely played cod for
the longest time because all my hopes
was kind of set on
on 2042 you know and that fizzled out
but this should be fun i'm squad leader
we got squads oh sh let's go
is the kilo good again i don't know if
the kilo is good but personally i just
like how it feels oh [ __ ] okay okay okay
um
so we see godzilla here we see kong here
let's just
oh my god there he is
there's the boy
look at him
look at him
what the hell
oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay i gotta get
fully
enemies
so let's just shoot him oh oh oh he's
right
oh my god
okay
jesus
i guess we're gonna i guess i gotta
chase him down
can i hop in a jet
oh let's go
problem is i've never flown in cod so
this is gonna be it's gonna be bad
oh god oh the sensitivity on this is so
bad
all right let's go let me get some
get a good angle on him
i see godzilla in the bottom
see some other jets
i cannot turn fast enough all right
let's just go to godzilla then oh looks
like he's going under uh
looks like he's going underwater
[Laughter]
that ain't no jet yeah you're right i
made that mistake in uh
in a battlefield video actually oh i
gotta return to the combat area
oh he's mad mad
oh he is mad man
how close you think i can get to him
they got a health bar and everything
a damn boulder
so i guess we're collecting intel by
shooting
oh my god
oh that is funny
kong staggered nice
yeah i'm like swinging my mouse just to
just
turn i wonder how long he can get away
with this
oh we got an enemy jet
these are the moments where i wish i had
a controller
i think it's technically both
it's a pve
vp
mode because you're fighting
two behemoths
um but but i'm pretty i'm pretty sure
there are enemies though
i mean i was just shooting trying to
shoot down a jet
i'm not entirely sure
if that was an ai
i don't think it was though
well i'm collecting a lot of intel but
kind of wanna
oh my god
oh did i kill someone with my
plane
while it was flying
what
yeah dude i got
i doubt someone
with my [ __ ] plane
it's so funny oh my god on your tail
yeah sucks suck bro
oh you can mount this uh
it's the air turret
okay that's just for the let's just for
the planes
where's our boy
that's a lot of xp
oh god oh god no have mercy have mercy
[Applause]
apologies in advance there's a there's a
slight delay um
there's a slight delay with uh with the
the chat obviously so my responses are
going to be a little late
but yeah it seems like i'm looking at
the chat now it seems like you guys just
saw that uh that wild um plane kill
[Laughter]
just which is sick
so it looks like there's no revives
um
or maybe i pressed the wrong button but
seems like there's no revives like no
gulag or anything like that so once
you're once you're out you're out
um
but it's cool that the live event
is up for like
or it's rather it's not a live event but
it's like a limited time mode you know
someone's saying they don't hear the
game
i say cap bro i think i think you can
hear the game if it's low though let me
know and i'll and i'll i'll raise it
it's rebirth rules
someone explain me what that means
oh okay i see there's if you have a
squad okay gotcha
use this time to train a bit we'll be
deploying soon
someone asked me if the kilo was meta
earlier
and
i don't think it is but
i just i just love that gun i mean even
back from i want to say like maybe
modern warfare
i was using it so i just like the way it
sounds i like
i like a lot of things about
about this gun
audio is fine all right thanks for uh
thanks for confirming y'all
that's quite funny the way they they
tactical sprint
sup sup
15 seconds to nail one of these bozos
i got two
training's over
time to see what you've learned come on
as long as one teammate's live right on
so if anything maybe i should uh
after this after this round i should
just hop in on like a uh a squad you
know
and just like
[ __ ] off and
keep respawning
all right so we messed with kong earlier
maybe we should go to godzilla although
godzilla seems a little more difficult
because he's out in the water so there's
not much you can do
okay yeah so they always spawn and kind
of the same oh
oh we're right over godzilla
hostile dropping into the area watch the
skies
take our enemies
dude the thing is that i like
i get such a headache trying to
keep track of all the the loot that pops
out like the early game you know
50 still reminds me i feel like with
fortnite it's easier to um
it's kind of easier to like figure out
like what you're getting you know
everything so clearly
clearly indicated it's a little harder
on this one but
no biggie
so i got a kill streak though i wonder
if i could pop it on uh
pop it on godzilla you know what i mean
let's
guess it's moving
okay so i gotta collect the crate nearby
so we'll do that
stay alive long enough to gather
important intel
target mark send it
got your requests
it called the cluster strike and replace
with the roof
where'd homeboy go
oh i hear someone though
yep
oh there's no one in this team for me to
play with them again all right we're
going to load it with squat this time
so at least uh people can keep
respawning
that have been sick if i could have
popped those uh the other dude though
i'm shocked they didn't kill each other
it seems like it was like a free-for-all
so
that's fine
it's taking a long time to get to the
to get to the menus
i wonder if we're uh
lagging at her
check your gear and weapons oh now i
just popped this into another round here
let me let me leave this match i can uh
load it in with the squad
you think i was playing against quads is
what it was that time
maybe
maybe
maybe
oh
yeah that might be it
is there a way to uh
are you just okay oh here we go yeah
i had a sense of don't fill
this whole time man i've been trying to
1v4 for y'all huh
it's like a [ __ ] shroud or something
that's so funny
yeah i'm just that good right
i'm just gonna go in
one before and get get my ass answered
to me
paintball says i just don't get the
point like yeah it's cool seeing the
monsters fight but what is the purpose
what do they add to the game
that's a good question you know i if if
you know we want to get a little a
little real here it's it's just a you
know it's kind of a
that's what live service games do now
you know what i mean um really like they
they need something to just
add that level of uh
add that like
you know quote-unquote content right
it's
like this isn't really for someone who
never played cod or warzone and needs a
reason to get into it this is for those
who
for the guys who have just been playing
this all the time and maybe they're a
little burnt out and they just want
something different you know
so
it's um the the purpose of the add to
the game really is is just like giving
it like a different it's like a
different flavor you know for the for
the core
audience at least that's the way that i
look at it because like i play a lot of
destiny for example like a lot and they
do stuff like this um all the time you
know
they got halloween events they got
spring events they got christmas events
valentine's day events things like that
um and even just like random like right
now there's an event called guardian
games it's kind of like
it's like the olympics
and uh
you know
it's it's it's fine it's not it's not
enough to like sell someone who
probably wouldn't like the game anyway
is how i look at it but but if you'd
like you know if you if you play a lot
of war zone and you play a lot of cod
with your with your buddies like
i think this is fine
i do i will say i do miss
the days of good premium
um
story campaign-driven
uh shooters
you know i mean everything is i mean
multiplayer will always be more popular
there's nothing wrong with that but you
know my my first call of duty was
uh the og one and then like big red one
unlike the ps2 and stuff
uh medal of honor things like that but i
was like a kid you know and so
you just played campaign missions
shooting up a bunch of bunch of nazis
right
and then like god like 2007 2008 i was
in high school and modern warfare 2 came
out from 360. and that game literally
convinced me to get a 360. it was so
sick
you know
and so we're i mean we're going to get
him on work for two this year actually
so i'm really excited for that and
oh that boy looks sick
so i got a grim reaper scythe and
everything oh that's so cool
all right robert fishing you wanna
you wanna mark the map for
me all right
let's go and your kia teammates will
redeploy any point worthy action will
return them to combat quicker
hostile drop it into the area watch the
skies
someone grabbed that jet enemies to grab
their intel that's not good
damn i
swear really abandoned me
[Laughter]
that's all right
let's see what chad's doing while i'm
running around
oh okay yeah paintball i see what you're
saying um yeah i think i think it's for
i think it's for for warzone fans you
know or for for cod fans and that
happened to like
you know king kong and godzilla if
you're only a king kong godzilla fan i'm
not
entirely sure
if hopping into call of duty is suddenly
the right decision for you you know what
i mean i think i think it depends
um
but oh damn dude he can jump
squad member is redeploying
but yeah so you know
you got some folks say oh medal of honor
is the best it was it was really good my
first medal of honor was uh frontline
and then there was european assault
which i really liked
i don't trust this this gun for me to be
able to hit oh god i'm so [ __ ]
i'm so [ __ ]
family
i'm out of ammo
they just abandoned this boy dude they
just abandoned him
oh you poor thing
[Laughter]
they're like ah you can respawn [ __ ] up
oh boy
that was so good
uh what's my favorite cop campaign uh
modern warfare 2 i think
um so the thing was i played modern
warfare 2 first
and then oh there's smoke coming damn i
forgot about that i forgot about the gas
um
i played modern warfare 2 first and then
i played modern warfare 1 uh you know
it's like i did it all out of the out of
order
but modern warfare 2 oh my god dude
changed my life changed my life that
campaign was so
sick
and so haunting
um
so i wasn't a uh
i wasn't with with uh captain price
right off the bat you know what i mean
like i was i was actually a
soap was my guy
oh hey
this ain't stuck
yeah but so soap was my guy and soap and
roach you know what i mean
and and those two were
the dudes that first mission
on the ice by the cliffs
when uh
when soap looks at you and is like all
right roach like let's go he flicks his
leg cigar and everything dude you can't
uh can't beat that
black house was really good too
black ops was really good i remember
that one had like you know huge twist
like what do the numbers mean and all
that stuff um
into like
hallucinations and [ __ ] that was really
cool but i don't know maybe it's just
because modern warfare was my first or
modern warfare 2 was my first you know
what i mean
so it's hard for me to um
it's hard for me to put like a uh
a cap on that like it's just
it's just the best for me
and it always will be
um but you know what i actually did like
i liked the modern warfare um
the 2019 that was that was cool dude
modern warfare 2019 was so sick
granted there were some really bad
liberties that they took
with historical accuracy
um
but beyond that
i cannot aim uh but beyond that i
thought like the combat and the uh the
clear house mission and all that was so
cool
so
oh boy
[Applause]
help me squad help me squad i'll be
scrapped
oh boy
oh i'm so scared
[Applause]
nice
[ __ ] team
also shooting at us
i hear someone
what is this
you're like a zip line
um anyway sorry chad i got super
distracted
but yeah dude freaking yeah moderator
for 2019 was so sick
um but my word for two definitely my
favorite black ops also sick um i had
black ops 2
in college
but my boys and i
mainly just used that for um
for zombies
that was like all we played it for and
then i actually had my copy of black ops
2 stolen and i just dorm life right if
you if you
those of you in college in the dorms
right now
probably had your [ __ ] jacked before
i guess people were just jealous because
we were all broke no one could afford it
and i was lucky enough to save and drop
60 bucks for black ops 2.
those are the days
oh [ __ ]
now
[Laughter]
oh and the smoke's going no he's started
again
oh
that ain't right
i see the enemies
what am i decrypting
oh
oh i'm dead
i was good though
yeah well at least my squad's alive i
should be able to respawn right that's
what you guys are saying
i was going to survive
for okay for like eight more seconds
uh yeah let me catch up i'll chat with
y'all i'll please stay alive dog i only
got
model for games have the best story
someone asked this battlefield 2045
worth it i'm sure you mean 2042
and uh
well i'm not
i'm not pushing that
oh but i did spawn with the weapon okay
i guess it's just random there's someone
here though
for so long
that's a good time for me to catch up on
chat actually
black ops one is michael cobb's favorite
game
that's a good one
everyone's saying black ops 1 is really
cool that's probably when i mentioned
black ops huh
godzilla where godzilla's by the ocean
we could probably
stop by him at some point
someone said no one he's never played
modern for
2019 but you're gonna play model for
2022 because people have
high expectations for it
yeah sounds about right oh boy
hello kong
yeah you're not wrong dude i mean
i thought i was gonna die
you're not wrong i think i think people
have really good um high expectations
for the game uh for good reason because
2019 was really good and it's just like
a good premium
cod event like nothing against warzone
but it kind of lacks that that premium
factor you know what i mean
and there's not much you can really do
about that
but um
addy asked me do i remember no russian
of course i remember
of course i remember
i think it was one of my my favorite
things about um
this is one of my favorite things about
modern worker 2 was the different
perspectives
you know you played as ally and you
played as uh goes ramirez
play as roach
he's all really really sick where's my
squad
oh there we go
sick
why godzilla and kong didn't that movie
come out three years ago
you know
i think it's more of
did you just
blow up
you've collected intel for operations
and for those of you who like don't know
me i i
literally i think my favorite thing in
video games has to be
people blowing up
it never gets old into me you know what
bob jones i will absolutely do that like
this is literally
it's like all i like to do in games is
just
[ __ ] around
oh there's a bunch of gold stuff here
though okay
[ __ ] it
we do it live
all right here we go chat i'm doing this
for you okay
we're going
straight kamikaze
straight kamikaze
well that wasn't
i could have been cooler
they should fight yeah they should
that's kind of what i was expecting to
happen
you know you guys might you guys might
hate fortnite in chat but fortnite had
an event uh a couple years ago where it
was like uh it's like a kaiju
vs mecca event
bob you and i both bro
you and i both
go back to
i'm being shot at
good thing the guy has [ __ ] aim
but so do i
so
oh no no no
[Laughter]
that's what i get for talking [ __ ] dude
i'm like he's got [ __ ] i'm just like
that's so much fun
um oh i'm sorry addy you asked earlier
if i was playing on pc or console i am
playing on pc yeah i
i do like to play uh console
a lot um especially for shooter stuff
but um
but to be
completely honest uh when it comes to
shooters and not completely sucking uh
it just feels better being on mouse and
keyboard
that's no
guarantee obviously oh what is he gonna
do
nice
um but
but yeah
so i'm playing on pc
someone said no more respawning is that
true
oh [ __ ] okay well i guess i gotta
actually
uh not be a kook about it
is he
oh god
oh
my god come on
once again smashed by uh
by a rock or something
oh yeah yeah
good [ __ ] bro
i appreciate it
here
see a bunch of dudes there
trying to get to that loadout drop but i
think i just got to get back to my
buddies
seems like
we're close to uh
being the last group gas is closing in
relocating
oh yeah this circle is tiny off
this is my first resurgence uh
yes
it's disabled and i have uav
recons online
you ate me beginning fly over
great shout out chad
i mean they got to come to us right
yes he's moving
yeah i see him
i wish i had something a little more
long range
that was nasty
let's see one more
oh
that was uh
thought i had a grenade but i had a
syringe instead
hey
let's [ __ ] go
did you look at that
that was for you chat whoever shouted
out that uav
it's all you
g [ __ ] g y'all
rush him it's one on three
yeah shut up huh
look at us man
who would have thought
not me
sick
i'll play with that
i'll play with that team again
geo plays war zone way too much
[Laughter]
right on my dude look at that titan
damage
what the hell
oh you know what that was because i
launched like eight [ __ ] panzer
like rockets into the
in the godzilla
those are some pretty good long shots
though actually i'm thinking about it
especially i had like an smg
shooting like i had like a scout rifle
or something
y'all i threw out my back today by
sleeping
you ever do that
you're like ow ugh
you're so inactive
that you you get a cramp or you throw
your back out by doing nothing at all
maybe it's an age thing maybe i'm just
getting old
we got joining in with us where are you
guys from so i know we got a couple of
east coasters we definitely got some
pacific
homies like myself but
we got any international folk here we
all uh
are we all just goofy americans
stretch too far in bed once i pull the
muscle in my leg bro
i am with you
on that
so
it happens all the time for me
i actually um
yeah what are these load times bro your
guess is as good as mine man and i got
an ssd too
we are 100 running on an ssd so
oh [ __ ] all right hello from sri lanka
hello from australia indonesia and the
uk welcome welcome
american living in japan that is
that's tight
i got a brother from wales
that's cool man that's awesome
i love i love i love i love when uh
we get international folk here i used to
i used to travel to germany a lot
because i got i got family there
uh everyone on my mom's side a bunch of
bunch of cousins live in uh uh frankfurt
so every summer i'd fly to uh i'd fly to
germany as a kid and i love europe man
absolutely love it
i've traveled to europe more than i've
traveled within my own [ __ ] country
man i swear
the only places i've been in america are
uh
you know if you want to consider socal
and norcal independent states
and then vegas i guess
ah rachel from germany guten tag
wilcomen yeah
i think
um
hello from jordan
and greetings from chile
one of my best friends is uh is chilean
this is my old college roommate
his name is dom you might know him by
his gamer tag bugs and nugs 420.
not even making that up i wish
i was but that's 100 his gamertag
absolutely love that guy
and every time we'd play fifa he would
uh
every time he played fifa he would uh
play as chile
and he scored a bunch of goals on mia
sanchez tonight
rage quit
ah ciao from tuscany hey
i i spent uh i spent a summer in italy
shooting a documentary for for school
and uh at the uh the bossier de
montevero
it was really really cool
hello from brazil practice is over the
real fight begins now romero from
chicago hello hello
yeah fox uh italy was sick too man
i loved my time there i went to uh
i went to uh uh i spent a day in
before i went to rome i spent a day in
uh uh what was it near uh in bologna
and uh
actually got my wallet stolen
it wasn't the best day but
i was i was doing some debauchery
debauchery [ __ ] and gotten some trouble
but
all right squad where we where we
hopping
oh okay
survive i will look
forward i went all the way back there
okay
i will
[Music]
oh
i'll have more to share about italy uh
after i die
it's so hard for me to like multitask
man i don't know i don't know what
happened i used to be so good at it and
i just like absolutely cannot multitask
for the life of me anymore
it's like heart adhd was i just scanned
someone like
pop scanner is that why my
my body started
glowing
oh someone's definitely been here
so i'm curious too i wonder
the revives is it you can only like
expel a certain number of revives before
it runs out or is it like a time thing
like once you get to um
once you get to like
x
circle you know
that's when um
they just like stop revise for everyone
you know what i mean
that's what i'm trying to like figure
out
i got a shotgun we got a green
rapid fire ar
i don't know how to use my heartbeat
sensor actually so
we'll see
fulfilled long enough
okay i'm starting running to my squad
bali indonesia you bet i never come
i don't know man never say never
indonesia's got some good uh get some
some good surf spots
i'll never say no
to a good surf trip
too bad i suck at surfing though
i learned in uh in college and
water's too cold
in the bay area
it's a lot better if you're in uh san
diego
even santa barbara's got some good surf
damn
we're gonna have to hoof it huh
okay it looks like they're going to go
towards kong so
this is the part of battle royale
everyone loves huh you just
you just run
take damage from geysers if it's like
hot enough
ah kong come on my
guys play nice
third place
fourth place
i have no idea how we're getting points
but let's go
i'm trying to climb scale a [ __ ]
mountain
earlier out of you asked dude do i think
ea would be much better
do i think ea will be much better than
with fifa i assume you mean will ea be
better with fifa
uh and no
fifa and madden
[Music]
even 2k even though that's not ea
they're not they're not going to change
man
i'm still going to play them you know i
got they're they're the best
sports sim
out there and they have you know the
up-to-date rosters but i uh
i'm still going to play them but yeah no
i don't i don't expect them to get
better the only thing you can do is
boycott uh ultimate team
you shooting at my guy
oh lord he coming
well i got a munition so i'm just going
to empty a clip into them
for the x-speed because why not
[Applause]
you know my uh my boss and i
erin we uh we had a
shooter chat recently
talking about
uh the state of some shooters and like
cod and
and overwatch and things like that and
for cod we obviously were talking about
the uh
the event and we were like hey you know
it's always funny how
people seem to think that bullets will
actually do something to these guys
i'm just gonna piss them off man
hello from ukraine hello
welcome hope you are hope you are safe
if you really are
from ukraine appreciate you uh joining
in man
god bless
at some point all this uh
all the stuff in the ground just like
blurs and i don't know what like
anything
anything means
i guess my team's camping out
i guess i'll be one last time yeah
oh so it seems like there's like a
window
where uh
damn that bullet job uh it seems like
there's a window that you can damage
these um these enemies and if you damage
them enough you see that bar at the top
it like loads up
um
and you get a reward crate if you're the
top four
so it seems like my group did the most
so far i guess out of everyone else
doing damage
which is why we're in first
but
can the titans die i don't think so man
i don't think they die i think they just
stagger you know it's meant to like
it's meant to just like mess with the
map a little bit you know what i mean
so
this is a couple of you in my forehead
[Laughter]
thanks g
i don't know if you mean my forehead
from just holding down w because i tend
to do that
a lot
uh
in these games but
you know
oh there's someone here man
it's gotta be up top
oh yep yep
damn it
[ __ ] knew it
never go up those things it takes
forever to like unhook yourself
yeah look at that he had all the time in
the world
he had all the time in the world
that's all right
but i think i'm not going to spawn with
the cool um
the armor pads anymore unfortunately
that's okay
nicola what's the event like
it's like uh it's like normal war zone
it's a normal war zone but with um
no warzone but with the twist i guess
you could you could say
you know
oh i see a boy right there
guy you guys think i could sneak up on
him
oh never mind
never mind
his boy came down
uh yeah let's just
do that
oh and he had a thermal scope
he had me did their rights
christian hello from peru hello
and again guys sorry if my you know my
shout outs are going to be real real
late because there definitely is a chat
delay
and my brain can't really multitask but
i see you guys i love all y'all
and i really appreciate you guys joining
stream is like the best part of my day
man i don't do it enough
but
whenever i do get a chance
it's always a good time i always get
nervous before streams you know
like i worry my pc is going to blow up
where my cat's going to infiltrate my
room
like embarrass the [ __ ] out of me
how
did i not
kill anyone
that sucks i have no [ __ ] ammo
oh he had really good armor that's why
the one thing i will say about warzone
that like throws me off is everywhere it
looks the same
it's hard for me to
got some redemption for y'all
i already have one
you know what i could use though some
dropping ammo the area gas is closing in
relocating the safe zone
reinforcements are on the way
i hear some dudes behind me
what are your allies
oh no
i should have looked to my left man that
was a stupid play on my part
i just tunnel vision man
like joseph said i got a great i got a
great forehead
oh boy
let me
refresh that okay
25 remain solid work so far
back in the
action
i could use some ammo
[Music]
god damn it
he had to have been hurt
oh wait no no
provide me so i don't have to wait
look at the way i'm like
oh yeah maybe it's not good for me to
put my teammate in danger to try to
revive
oh but he's a
hero he's a hero
let's go
oh
my god
i got too cocky
just looking the wrong way
seems like no revives are gonna
[Music]
yeah revives are no longer active now
which sucks so does that mean
i should be able to get a revive though
now because my
uh countdown happened
before
right that's that's got to be my guess
but it's going to suck because i'm not
going to have any uh
any ammo this time
[Laughter]
that's so good
holy [ __ ]
yeah we gotta add a front a front seat
view to that man
oh my god
oh [ __ ] is that the time
damn i think i was supposed to end the
stream 10 minutes ago
[ __ ] it [ __ ] the rules yeah
we'll keep going for a little bit longer
oh
right right right right
chad let me know if you guys are still
there y'all been a little a little too
quiet
a little too quiet you gotta
gotta get some combos going on
ask me 20 questions
take me out on a date tell me i'm pretty
otherwise i'm just going to keep saying
some cringe [ __ ] like this
until you guys make me stop
hope you guys are ready for another 10
minute [ __ ] loading screen again
oh
[Laughter]
joker killer is like yeah now we out we
gone there ain't no one here no more
like 20 people just bailed they're like
yeah now i've had enough of this [ __ ]
is the mechagodzilla bundle out yet i
think it is yeah for the you're talking
about like the skins and stuff
it definitely is i think it went live
um when season three launched
i could be wrong but that i'm pretty
sure it went live when season three
launched which was like two weeks ago
a lot of shooters had some updates man i
swear
like
you know cod vanguard warzone they all
had their season three
um overwatch two
overwatch two had that uh um
freaking what should we call it the uh
[Laughter]
jumped
i'm so easily distractible man
so good
yeah he was mad
david martin
come on man we're both davis you should
you should uh have my back here
telling me to step up my play
from one david to another i'm
disappointed in you
damn dog
got any more bullets
preparations done josh is trying to
start a revolution in chat can you get
everybody to bail
yeah guys leave leave i don't even want
you here go and uh um
go check like ign or something
i'm just playing i don't want to get
fired
telling you guys to go to my competitors
dude look at this dudes
[ __ ] pot
that guy has the snoop dogg bundle
all gillied up with some
some good ol
some good old guns
all right squad where we dropping
they don't want to drop all right
maybe we'll just go
peek all right let's do it
live and your kia teammates will
redeploy
any point worthy
oh the block is hot
yeah
[Music]
yeah
hostile dropping
damn
well i got
left to dry
i don't know how many parachutes i got
all right let's just get kitted up and
go join our uh
join our boys
where's this 12 gauge
on a pistol
oh we are right on kong's ass
[Applause]
[Applause]
can you self-revive yourself multiple
times
okay there it is
[Applause]
nice work
big boss i'm curious what you uh what
you're hoping so i was what i kind of
thought was going to happen i thought it
might be like a fortnight event so you
just hop in
and like you just see something happen
it's almost like like a controlled
environment you know
you hop in you see them like break
something maybe the map changes
and then um
and then you would just play warzone
like normal seems like they kind of went
with like a middle of the
middle of the road approach here
you know what i mean so it's like you're
actively playing warzone but kong and
godzilla are just kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
up in the background
so
but yeah it's i mean it's nothing it's
something
super big you know what i mean but
i'm also i also don't think let's make
this quick um
i also don't think there's really much
you could
realistically want you know what i mean
but
it is what it is
david you're good don't have been doing
any trip bro
i'm just goofing around you know what i
mean so
i don't know if you were here earlier uh
david but we actually had a dub and it
was it was a pretty fun one
uh it was super unexpected i was like
learning warzone
i was learning out [ __ ] revives and
uavs and rebirth worked
uh dude my squad is way
the [ __ ] out
i'm like scared man i got
i'm like scared to go up i feel like i'm
gonna get jumped
let people with the high ground
i'm just gonna start going towards the
circle
no messes rather being for it dude
listen
oh i'm lagging uh listen dude man to
fortnite's credit they handle this stuff
really well granted they also like
plagiarize the [ __ ] out of all their
best ideas right
among us mode like come on
but um
beyond that man i mean
fortnite
has really pioneered the live service
not the live service i should say but um
the live event
type [ __ ]
like for real
you know what i mean
just gonna unload on him real quick
that's awesome
i'm probably gonna die i'm looking for a
fight now
i'm looking for a fight
i'm probably
what are your
seems like a peashooter
i feel like there's one more dude back
there that i like missed out
hostile on into the area watch the skies
y'all i'm not gonna lie to you i don't
remember what my keybind for my grenade
for operation is
that's your brother
yes it is
i'm so [ __ ] dude
run
you bastard
[ __ ] there's actually no point me
self-reviving so i'm just gonna
die into the gas
damn that's unfortunate
man yeah oh my god
oh well
hopefully my team stays a lot nope
oh he's about to die too
okay sick
colt's still alive so
uh is this the future of halo style sky
boxes
maybe
wants a new godzilla game where he plays
godzilla but we'll never get it again
that makes me hella sad same my guy same
big oh
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] that was gold
that was gold man that's what happens
when you're distracted
if you think you're safe reading chat
you're not
[Laughter]
oh that's fun
oh my god
place tent though that's good
that's a decent round though
all right my friends it's around that
time but i'll do uh let's do one more
let's do one more good one
just mess around shoot
shoot mr king kong a little bit
those of you earlier in chat
they were telling me where uh you know
all the cool places you guys were tuning
in from
i hope you guys are all doing well that
was really cool man we had someone from
italy
got some from germany a couple of folks
from the from the united kingdom
people on the west coast the east coast
south america
so sick man
god i
i gotta say i think
thinking back earlier to how uh
i think back earlier to the beginning of
the stream man the coolest part had to
have been
you know it's it's king kong and
godzilla
if you stay away from them during these
modes like i gotta say for those of you
that that end up wanting to check this
mode out and you hop in to war zone you
do the update and you want to see what
operation monarch's about
if you say the further away that you are
from them the less funny and fun it is
you know what i mean
but
if you're there
in on the action you know you see kong
just like level
an entire section like you know three of
your buddies are alive and all of a
sudden they're not like it's just
i feel like that you gotta you just
gotta keep it hot you know you gotta
like dive in and and keep the fire
fights near them to make the mode
kind of more engaging otherwise you're
just you're just playing in like a
normal battle royale right
but
i feel like these load times are
probably because so many people are are
checking out the mode at least for today
and if you can't get to
the game mode today don't worry because
it's going to be live for i think 14
days
is uh what the timer says it's like two
weeks so you got time you got time to
check out the new season and i'm pretty
sure it is the mode is free to play uh
you know because warzone itself is free
to play you don't need to own vanguard
you don't gotta
buy cold war
or you know 2019's modern warfare none
of that you can just install warzone
it's like an 80 gig installer or
something like that on on
a pc
which is
but
uh you know i i think back in the day
man you had a you had a freaking buy
like a 250 if you had a 250 gig hard
drive it wasn't even enough to install
all of modern warfare that's the thing
philanthropy it's weird to me that they
aren't running it like the vanguard
reveal thing with the train it's kind of
lame that the br is still going on
during it man yeah you know like so you
know a couple of folks i think nomad
earlier in chat was talking about
fortnite and and how uh
how you know like fortnite would kind of
handle this stuff it it you'd expect it
to be more of like a like a team battle
you know
like if i had to speculate i would say
in fortnite you had
because yeah yeah you have the the big
team battle so it's like 50 ver it's
like 50 v 50 or 20 v20 right
you'd probably do it like that i mean
these servers the operational monarch
servers it's only 60 players it's not
150 player servers you know um
although i guess it's i don't know if
that's 60 like squads or if it's 60
players but i'm assuming it's 60 players
which means you could have easily done a
30 v30
make it like a co-op
you know you could pick a team at random
like it just spawns you in like all
right you guys are team king kong
and the rest of you are team godzilla
right and you just go at it you know you
go at it maybe you have a timer or
something and and you know whoever
defeats the other ones
behemoth first like wins right and you
got respawns and and everything you take
out other players and maybe you like
killing enough players would get you
like some kind of uh power up or bonus
and it seems like they kind of went
halfway but didn't fully commit
um
to the idea unfortunately you know
so like although it's still kind of cool
and still kind of fun i know bob jones
earlier in on uh
joining us from twitch he uh
suggested i i do a kamikaze flight into
godzilla which i was all for
and we were hoping that'd be cool and
like you know all that happened was the
screen went super like gray because it
was out in the
in the gas zone and then he just blew up
and was like oh okay
i guess that's it you know
so
it also doesn't help that i'm like
playing like a like a kook
this is so distractible just running
around trying to kind of be friends with
uh
with king kong
expect this lobby to fill up a little
faster though
oh we got run over
that's so funny
yeah i don't know man it's like
it feels like it's one of those things
where like the gimmick wears off
you know after i feel like after a
couple of hours unless if you're just in
it for war zone like for the the core
war zone part
you know you see you've seen everything
you need to see but
it'd be cool if it they let you unlock
like exclusive goodies or maybe some
skins or things like that instead of
just locking it behind the um
behind the the
cosmetic store but
it is what it is what can you do
all right my friends let's do this make
this a good one it's probably gonna be
the last one
i'll let y'all decide if i should go
near uh godzilla or king kong
if the chat loads fast enough before uh
before i have to jump out of the plane
oh there's my boy with the snoop dogg
ghillie suit again
i'm the squad leader okay well we're on
godzilla's side so
let's go
to godzilla
survive to redeploy fallen teammates and
earn points
man i gotta say
the parachutes are so weird in call of
duty i feel like
i feel like you're not going anywhere
and you're going super fast at like the
same time
also for those of you who can explain to
me i actually don't know what the trophy
system is this thing that i pick up
i couldn't tell if it was like a turret
or if you're just supposed to
plop it anywhere and get some kind of
like xp or progress for it
dude all these
all these departments look the same i'm
literally retreading
uh like walking in my own uh my own
shadow
i just want some good guns i just want
something good
but i could shoot at him that's all
i'm just gonna throw that trophies in
here i don't even know what it does
oh maybe it's like a scanner you know
what i mean
uh
i'll take
yeah i'll take the smg
actually i'll take this too because i
hate pistols
it's a little quiet though
a little too quiet oh someone's
definitely been in here
hello
sucks for you
oh man oh man oh man
i wonder what that i can't tell if
that's like a health bar for king kong
or if that's like his frenzy meter you
know what i mean
like are you supposed to supposed to
make that red bar go lower or
max it out all the way
it's hard
to tell
dude you know shooting those bullets at
godzilla
it gives me the same
it gives me the same energy of when you
give
your little brother or sister
player three's controller and then you
unplug it so they think they're playing
with people or not and they're like i'm
helping that's that's me right now
trying to shoot godzilla i feel like i'm
actually doing something you know what i
mean
like it's more fun trying to hunt people
down
than it is feeling like i'm doing
something
to godzilla
guess is moving in use safe zone
highlighted
[ __ ]
that's my bad
don't shoot gojira
kudos to you for for uh
referring to him by his real name
oh dark travis i'm assuming yeah you
were talking about what the trophy
system did
so i appreciate that uh that answer that
makes sense someone chucks uh uh
you know
strap on grenades or something like that
and just all
clears it all out for you
oh my homie was on a
on a turret that's why he's just going
ham right now
did you all see all that loop just
disappear i'm
pretty sure i saw
a bunch of loot disappear
there's definitely a dude down there
back in the game
still don't have any
ar elegy
oh boy
oh
enemy soldier nearby
oh [ __ ]
something way too late
don't shoot my zilla
write my name in the death note
really
you're gonna write my name in the death
note just because uh i shot your
godzilla
well i'll do it again
i know i said that was the last one but
i'm not gonna end on that now
top five or bust
oh yeah
bro don't rush dude all i know how to do
is rush that's the problem
that's all i do
i just i just forehead uh
i just hold w down there's a playlist
update available
what
i got to say man for those of you who
don't usually play call of duty it's so
daunting in the beginning just dealing
with its um with like the client and
like the ui and all that
because they they've tried to
mesh everything in together
but you don't necessarily have to have
everything installed so it's this weird
like half measure of
you know them trying to cram
modern warfare vanguard and warzone
all together
and then at the same time you know
you could like piecemeal it and like
kind of play things all a cart and it's
like wait what
so it's kind of bizarro but
all the time whenever i boot up the game
you know just to see what's up they
always like tell me like oh you gotta
install like a gig of of shaders or
textures it's like what does that even
mean
like why do i why can't you just
streamline it and i guess i guess the
reason is because maybe in the beginning
when they streamlined the way that you
would install call of duty it just meant
that it was like a 250 gig
install
and you know the average the average
gamer isn't gonna have a
you know a crazy terabyte ssd on their
pc
um all the time so it's like
you know most people are just playing on
their on their ps4s
so it makes sense that they probably
have like different versions
for different platforms but
oh that is lag
so my bullets freeze in front of me like
the [ __ ] matrix
yeah chat this time it it will be the
last one
so
give me your uh your energy that i don't
i don't [ __ ] this
we don't end on a bad note
get at least uh at least a fun kill at
least some uh
give godzilla and king kong maybe a
little
a little itch with all the bullets that
we're shooting at him
definitely not gonna kill him but
okay
i like how the location just says
somewhere in the pacific
like they really don't know
all right we're all wearing some sick
masks got a good feeling
daddy chief is the squad leader all
right
mr chief let me know where uh
where are we dropping
maybe i'll uh
oh nope
they were like nah we don't want to go
there
actually no i want to use the recon
drone
i feel like that could be potentially
more helpful
all right let me go hide somewhere and
start
scoping some
[ __ ] out
okay so how does it works disease
defense or descent spaces ascend
can i really not go out this window
wow
you're kidding me all right
i guess we're gonna
we're gonna go out the front door
okay
you've got gas moving in
bounty target is up take them down
there's something useful over there
oh he just launched himself
got another trophy system here
all right
looks like spot's just hanging tight
my homie over there
got some
dudes over there
hey grant congrats
you and me both man
actually that's a lie i won i remember
winning my first warzone game i ever
played
uh on xbox
and then i like didn't play for like two
years
after the fact
i was like might as well quit while i'm
ahead you know
okay i see you dude there oh
meant to ping but whatever
oh sorry
a little jumpy
what are your allies is back in the game
come on squad let's go find some action
i wanna
i wanna shoot some dudes
spiderscope
nice work
excuse me
we've got some very bad low ground right
now there's definitely a dude on that
bridge right there
first
squad member is redeploying
contract failed your time ran out bro i
have no idea
how to navigate this
this area
oh
so
lucky there
come back lmg assault rifle i'll take
the assault rifle actually
it's crazy that all the weapons are
vanguard weapons
you want to do that real quick actually
is
i thought i heard a teammate earlier i
was going to see if i could try to mute
my squad because i don't want them
interrupting the stream but
seems like it should be fine
there she is thank you
doctor start posing towards the event is
bad
i mean yeah it you know
it's not it's not the best
so i'm not entirely
uh disagreeing with him but
the thing is
you know
these games in these modes they're only
as fun as you make them
you understand like
if if you go into
a mode like this and you expect the
worst you're going to get the worst
if you go into a mode like this in you
are just kind of
you know lukewarm on it then that's just
how it is but you know the last hour and
a half we've been
we've been messing around flying jet
flying planes into
godzilla and
i've been personally just dying and
laughing every time i see people explode
so you know
what is what it is
i think the thing with battle royale is
you can play to win or you can play for
fun
and i think i uh
i prefer playing for fun
you know when apex came out
um my boss
eric tay he used to always
he's used to always say that he'd like
uh he'd like a spicy round which meant
he would just drop into
like skull town or like the hottest
area with all the
all the action right off the bat and
just like keep loading in and i have to
say i agree with that
um
that method a lot
it's just more fun that way you know if
you die you die so what
he gets uh
you get to reload in eh let me get in
here
someone's shooting at you but
lego
can you shoot through the window is that
a thing
i don't want to do yet in case i scare
my driver but
oh someone is
oh i'm lagging again
anyone know how to mute squad mates
just looking for the options and i
couldn't quite find it
our campaign going kong smash
god i wish man
dude i love
i love when uh when your squad can drive
because i can't that's for sure oh okay
i guess i'm being abandoned
we go on foot
there's definitely a dude there's
definitely dude here
it's definitely a plane above us
imagine being able to control the titans
yeah that'd be tight man
bring up the start menu click on
scoreboard and mute all
oh
[Laughter]
bro i have no idea how to bring up the
start video actually or bring up the
scoreboard i don't know what my keybind
on uh
on pc is
it seems like mr daddy chief has muted
himself though so that's that's
good what's up godzilla
get some intel from here
[Applause]
overdrive
he is leveling the area
get them all lasered out
looks so paranoid someone's just gonna
like
pop up on us you know what i mean
playing a risky game using up all my
ammo
the godzilla's the good guy
i take in your team godzilla
oh
definitely meant to
do this but
kong's wrath and coming oh [ __ ] i gotta
get out of here
oh i gotta get out of this zone
oh please don't throw a rock on me
unless that red zone was the
my heavy drop
but last time i got leveled by kong
chucking a fat boulder
oh yeah there it is chuck that [ __ ]
i swear i saw someone here oh yep
can't tell this buddy's there
wow
y'all see that lag there
that sucks
well at least we're
it's my buddy's life so i'll be able to
respawn
but there goes all my uh oh my good i'm
a good loot
stay alive viper shot
where's mechagodzilla god man i
guess as good as mine
appreciate it
wish i had
something a little better but oh
is he trying to murder me
oh i do not like the sights on that
weapon holy [ __ ]
okay well i downed one
damn what are the odds of me spawning
with a
awful awful weapon
oh [ __ ] come to me bro
oh you stop reviving okay
oh what
damn that was rough
yeah he
nailed me
that's not bad playstation
it's good stuff
i had some titan damage 41k oh well
actually i think i i launched more uh
rockets at the dude that's probably what
it was
that was good though
it was a decent round it was pretty fun
got to run around in a vehicle got to
see uh
godzilla do his thing
leveled up a [ __ ] ton today by the way
like i started out it was like level
like
five or six for the new season or
something like that
so we've been we've been climbing up
climbing up the battle pass
yeah it looks like the
there's a bunch of bundles here
you got godzilla you got some e-notes
some that are vanguard exclusive the
gojira stomp
[Laughter]
oh boy
[ __ ] all right guys well i think that's
gonna do it i really uh i really
appreciate it for those of you who
turned out that was a lot of fun you
know for those of you just joined sorry
you missed all the even saw the action
but it was a it was a good time man
really especially for those of uh the
international viewers who tuned in i
know you know time zones are all out of
whack for most of you it's probably
you know well past uh
curfews or bedtimes and things like that
so the fact that you're here with us uh
means a lot to me man so
once again i am david ahmadi i'm a video
producer for gamespot you should
absolutely check out some of the videos
that i make i cover a bunch of shooters
man i do call of duty and fortnite and
destiny and we've got a lot of folks on
the video team that are just amped up
for uh for these games man and you know
every every day every other day we're
always putting up good content uh for
you guys so definitely check it out
but yeah man that's gonna do it for me
so i'm gonna sign off and i hope all of
you guys have a wonderful wonderful rest
of your day
evening
and week
so
much love catch you guys later